[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' atteinte d
interdire je reçois aujourd'hui eric nov
trois de ses romans les hanches de
laetitia la petite française est un bien
fou sont réédités en un gros volume chez
albin michel sous le titre les romans
d'avant on va voir pourquoi vanessa bd
limbs elle célèbre pianiste est
maintenant chef d'orchestre sort casta
diva un album où elle joue des opéras au
piano tout un art et à l'occasion du
200e anniversaire de la mort de napoléon
1er quart branda publie napoléon à
sainte-hélène chez perrin tout un roman
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de xxième siècle deux invités
réponse en images
voici celles de biens banda on va la
voir apparaître alors quelques
représente-t-elle et pourquoi celle-ci
alors écoutez j'ai pris une photo assez
personnelle parce que celle de mon fils
alexandre qui est néant notre 31 octobre
parce que aujourd'hui au moment des
voeux on me dit toujours on vous
souhaite une meilleure année que l'année
précédente hors en famille nous avons
connu une joie immense
celle de la naissance de mon fils donc
c'est un petit peu tout le paradoxe de
la vie en fait un aujourd'hui dans cette
période troublée il ya quand même des
bonheurs des grands bonheurs et
l'historien que je suis surtout d'une
période agitée que fut celle de la
révolution de l'empiré du consulat c'est
qu'en fait voilà les choses sont plus
complexes puis mêlée que au drame succès
de la joie et inversement bien sûr c'est
un peu banal de le dire de le rappeler
mais enfin on ce discours n'est n'est
pas très et puis très courant
aujourd'hui
alors longue vie à alexandre mais
pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas appelé
napoléon pourquoi personne n'appelle son
enfant napoléon même pas vous au 19ème
siècle au 10e au 19e siècle ça se
faisait encore d'appeler ses son enfant
napoléon mais bon pour le préserver dans
les cours de récréation c'est difficile
de d'appeler quelqu'un napoléon parce
que maintenant le prénom est vraiment
tellement identifié est devenu une
marque que c'est très difficile
donc si on a ce qu'on souhaite des
grandeurs à ses enfants vaut mieux
choisir alexandre d'accord va est un peu
moins voilà oui vanessa bd limbs elle
votre votre image à vous laisser vous
tout seul dans une grande salle vide
oui oui tout à fait c'est une image
d'archivé kg pris il ya un an un peu
plus dans le nord de la chine à harbin
grand theater et qui représente
désormais notre époque car ça c'est le
spectacle comme en face de nos artistes
donc quelqu'un a encore la possibilité
la chasse décès produira
sur scène mais ça c'est les spectacles
en face d'elle aux yeux oui c'est quand
même assez terrible hein on en reparlera
tout à l'heure en parlant de casta diva
eric neuhoff votre image à vous pourquoi
ce médicament bassesse et du dos du
prime parce qu'avant on en prenait pour
la gueule de bois
et aujourd'hui on a ça dans sa pharmacie
en prévision du coc vite donc on est
passé des lendemains de fête à la veille
du virus est bien dans son
[Musique]
eric 9 vous êtes écrivain journaliste
critique de cinéma albaret michel votre
éditeur rééditant en un seul gros volume
3 de vos romans les hanches de laetitia
la petite française est un bien fou sous
le titre les romans d'avant pourquoi
d'avant parce que sa date d'une période
que je ne vivrai plus jamais et puis
j'ai l'impression que celui qui les a
écrits n'est sans doute plus le même et
c'est ça qui m'a fait penser aux romans
d'avant comme titre générique et alors
c'est toujours très drôle de lire ou de
relire dans mon cas puisque j'en avais
lu au moins deux sur trois mais de
relire trois romans à certain nombre
d'années après leur parution les proches
de laëtitia date de 1990
la petite française c'est en 97 et un
bien fou en 2001 donc ça remonte un peu
et délires tous les trois la suite tout
à coup on voit des trucs est ce que vous
les avez relu vous à vendre à vendin
ambitions je n'ai pas voulu les relire
justement alors je sais pas si ça par
lâcheté ou par modestie mais j'aurais eu
trop peur de trouver que ses romans
étaient beaucoup mieux que ce que je
faisais aujourd'hui ou au contraire
serait eu peur d'avoir envie de corriger
ce qui ne plaisait pas et puis je pense
qu'un roman il faut le laisser intact
parce que certains auteurs quand ils
republie de viau livre les corriger se
trouve que c'est un peu déloyale parce
qu'on n'est pas même à 60 ans car 80 ans
et on doit garder cette espèce de
personnalités cette inconscience qu'on a
quand on est plus jeunes voudraient
quand on revoit la couverture dont la la
c'est marrant parce que la photo qui a
été placée sur la couverture
c'est une photo en noir et blanc comme
si vous les aviez écrit dans les années
50 vos romans bas un petit peu oui j'ai
l'impression que ça appartient au passé
complètement sa toutes ces histoires de
deux filles d'étudiants à toulouse
d'écrivains américains qui pique la
fiancée du narrateur pour moi le
ray blanc c'est un peu comme l'imparfait
dans les livres c'est quelque chose de
nostalgique et qui est un peu le côté le
velouté du romanesque ça induit tout de
suite une distance et une mélancolie
n'aurait blu ray pour moi le la
mélancolie c'est un peu la farine du
boulanger pour un romancier il ya un
côté françoise sagan a de fumeuse ça va
en tout cas très flatté je sais pas si
c'est assumé mais oui ça doit être très
très bon écrivain c'était la liberté le
style là le plaisir aussi on sentait que
ça n'était pas du tout un effort
pourrait le décrire de raconter des
histoires et je crois que les romands ça
doit être écrit en dans un état de de
joie c'est la récréation comme ça fait
partie des plaisirs de l'existence
les anges de laëtitia qui paraît en 1990
je la vis et 34 ans mais ça se passe
dans les années 70 quand vous sortiez de
l'adolescence j'étais déjà dans la
nostalgie
oui parce que j'aimais beaucoup les
films de louis malle le feu follet les
premiers truffaut les godard et chabrol
et j'aurais aimé vivre à l'époque où de
boulevard saint germain était à double
sens où les hommes étaient habillant en
tweed où on avait le droit de fumer
partout
et ouais si vous avez vécu à l'ailé à
une époque où on avait le droit de fumer
partout 1,5 à 3 i son point de vue par
tous ouais ouais mais moi je ne fumais
pas mais j'aimerais qu'on ait le droit à
nouveau aujourd'hui
mais j'imagine si je revois les années
70 ça ne me semblerait comme les années
50 dans mon esprit de l'époque
alors vous voyez bien comme la nostalgie
le côté hussards le côté de droite à
l'époque mitterrand était encore au
pouvoir
c'était un peu la trade marks des jeunes
romanciers il fallait confier l'époque
ce que vous faites un dans les anges de
laëtitia il fallait dire qu'on était né
trop tard dans un monde qui ne savait
plus s'amuser il y avait un côté snob a
peut-être mais le livre dans mon
souvenir c'était le journal intime d'un
camion de 19 ans en province alors donc
c'est
parfaite image de petit con en
littéraire et qui ne peut pas aimer son
époque parce que il a lu les classiques
qui se sent pas à sa place et il n'a
surtout pas envie de réussir le concours
de normale sup passe comme ça voudrait
dire devenir professeur et pour lui
ç'aurait été l'horreur dans toute sa
splendeur
oui confié l'époque à 19 ans c'est
normal de ne pas se sentir bien dans son
époque
g je crois que les gamins de 19 ans
aujourd'hui doit être très très mal à
l'aise en ce moment les mots mais je
rappelle que vous en aviez 34 quand vous
l'écriviez et les deux suivants vous
aviez presque 40 ans et et pourtant il
ya toujours cette idée qu au fond le
seul divertissement qui nous reste ce
sont les femmes que c'est un jeu
dangereux et ont faussé le sujet de ces
trois romans
bah oui parce que je crois quand on
écrit des livres pour décrire des femmes
c'est truffaut qui disait que le cinéma
c'est faire faire de jolies choses
jolies femmes valeur les romans c'est
peut-être aussi un peu pareil et décrire
les gestes d'une femme sa façon de
s'habiller de se déshabiller de
d'essayer de deviner ses pensées c'est
un petit peu ce qu'on aimerait atteindre
en écrivant des romans et c'est pour ça
que dans les livres les femmes sont plus
belles que dans la vie que la vie est
plus amusante plus intéressante plus
trépidante que la vraie vie et il n'y a
pas de temps mort dans les romans enfin
en tout cas on essaye c'est presque un
guide vos romans puisqu'à un moment vous
dit que les femmes sont plus belle dans
la pénombre ou plus sexy peut-être plus
sexy que les femmes sont plus belle à
paris qu'ailleurs
donc c'est presque la même somme c'est
presque un guide pour chercher les
belles phases je me souvenais pas de
gérer ça mais c'est normal parce que les
les belles femmes qui habitent en
province viennent à paris ces évidences
et d'ailleurs le côté parisien ça fait
rêver toujours c'est que paris c'est la
capitale de
de la beauté et de l'élégance de la
littérature et c'est pour ça que tout le
monde a envie quand on grandit en
province de venir dans la ville mais il
ya quelque chose qui n'est dans les
littératures autour de 1990 et notamment
par vous eric nov
c'est la volonté de s'ancrer dans une
époque en citant des titres de films des
titres de chansons et surtout des
marques
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de marques on
vit pas un whisky ont dit un vaste 69
il boit du tropicana y vas chez wimpy
bret easton ellis
il sera bien qu'elle gigolo un an plus
tard fait exerce alors une chose un
american psycho américaine sicko
pardonnez moi qui sort chez nous en 91
fait exactement la même chose alors de
façon encore plus systématique
mais pourquoi elle ce moment-là qu'est
ce qui vous semblait si intéressant dans
le fait de quelques chose que ne faisait
ni roger nimier ni françoise sagan il
citait pas des marques ici t'es même pas
des titres de livres encore moins des
titres de chansons à tout bout de champ
bah c'est peut-être aussi pour aller
plus vite dire de 69 au lieu d'une
boisson maltée de couleur brune ça va
plus vite et puis ça ça indique aussi
l'époque et le niveau social les marques
les vêtements le les noms de films aussi
parce que les films et des chansons en
tout cas à ce moment là pour là pour la
musique il n'était pas question
d'entendre à la radio un tube qui avait
plus de six mois et ça ça m'a
complètement à un moment ça allait les
slows sur lesquels on a dansé tel ou tel
été c'est des petites da des clignotants
qui s'allument et mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je n'écrirai plus avec
autant de marques dans un mois est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça s'est décuplée tant
est que maintenant il ya wikipédia il ya
internet on peut retrouver très
précisément ce qui se passe est tel jour
à telle date à l'époque faisait ça de
mémoire quand même ah bah oui même
aujourd'hui je vais pas tout le temps
sur wikipédia mais on se souvient tous
de nous on était campé des 10 a été
assassiné quand claude françois est mort
quand en 2001 quand les tours du world
trade center se sont effondrées ça ça
c'est une espèce de mémoire commune
il y en a pas tant que ça des moments
que tout le monde peut partager les unes
l'émotion elle n'être temps en temps de
l'actualité il ya le deuxième roman qui
est réédité dans les romans d'avancé une
la petite française qui est sorti en
c'est un roman dans lequel on se fiance
on se marie on se vouvoie l'héroïne
s'appelle bébé pas bébé comme brigitte
bardot mais bébé comme abb
tout ça est un peu désuet même pour 1997
c'était déjà un peu suranné un peu
provincial une fille qui se faisait
appeler bébé en 1997 y en avait pas des
masses
il y en avait près de davantage dans les
ben vous voyez que j'ai eu raison de me
relire les noms mais bébé c'était parce
que bon elle était plus jeune que le
narrateur puisse avoir un côté marrant
pour les petit surnom démodé parce que
moi le tout ce qui est demandé je trouve
ça plutôt une qualité c'est laisser les
choses à la mort de ma fille ne me
plaisent pas surtout en littérature est
effectivement dans un bien fou le
troisième roman lui qui sort en 2001
l'héroïne s'appelle mood haillan n'avait
pas non plus beaucoup enfin il n'avait
plus beaucoup en mai 2001 qui sait vous
vous écoutez les rolling stones ce qui
déjà à l'époque en 60 ans ou sinatra et
toutes les références absolument toutes
les références date au minimum de 30 ans
ben mode c'est un clin d'oeil à ma nuit
chez maud de rohmer évidemment ces films
de jim qui avait 30 ans oui qui était en
noir et blanc mais qui et qui tient sur
le coup mais bon ben pourquoi pas c'est
des petites
référence des clins d'oeil c'est pas
gênant du tout mais bon j'imagine
j'assume complètement ce côté
nostalgique 1 c c'est pour moi un défaut
du tout mais en fait j'ai compris
pourquoi ça s'appelle les romans d'avant
c'est parce qu'en fait vos romans parle
absolument pas d'époque dans lesquelles
vous vivez il parle d'avant bah ouais
parce que c'est laid romance et humour à
l'imparfait comme on dit ça mais là
parfait dans les deux sens du terme
c'est le passé mais c'est aussi la vie
qui n'est pas comment on aurait aimé
qu'elle soit et tout ce qui vous arrive
de biens et surtout de mal la tristesse
mais ça fait partie de de tous les
agréments c'est que dans un roman c'est
un peu comme une caméra avec le recul on
comprend mieux ce qu'est ce qui vous
arrive même si je suis assez allergique
à l'auto fiction on doit à la fois
témoigné du de l'époque dans laquelle se
passe le livre et surtout je tiens à ce
que les romans écrits par la part des
hommes racontent qui a dans la tête des
hommes
c'est ce que me des femmes aussi je
préfère savoir ce qui se passe dans la
tête des femmes en lisant des romans de
femmes oui vous pensez que au fond les
personnages féminins
on a beau les les faire vivre ils
restent impénétrables
alors docteur masculin bat davantage que
les personnages masculins si on veut
savoir ce qu'il ya dans la tête d'une
femme on a qu'à lire
colette sagan ou geneviève dormann des
gens comme ça c'est ça qui est
intéressant mais on peut aujourd'hui
voilà comment on dit saleuses le
melgueil mais c'est pas du tout pour moi
péjoratif de le regard d'un homme sur
une femme c'est pas forcément quelque
chose de dégoûtant
alors si on veut comprendre son époque
qu'est ce qu'il faut lire
eric neuhoff j'espère que non l'époque
d'aujourd'hui ne m'intéresse pas
beaucoup ce que j'aime bien celle et les
écrivains
que je lis et les films que je vois les
films que j'aime et puis étant donnée la
la période on est obligé de revoir un
tas de classique chez soi
et effectivement quand on compare on se
dit que c'était mieux avant hélas oui
mais je parlais pas seulement
d'aujourd'hui parce que si on regarde un
bien fou donc qui sort en 2001
le roman se termine à new york votre
héros a dû être sacrément surpris par
les attentats du 11 septembre parce que
rien dans le livre ne pouvait le laisser
le laisser attendre ou rien n'était là
pour faire comprendre ce qu'il se
passait autour de lui les coûts de frank
sinatra
ah ouais m'enfin c'est pas seul à ne pas
s'attendre à ça j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde a été sidéré de ce qui se
passait c'était d'ailleurs je disais
qu'à l'époque il y avait eu deux
catastrophes
c'était le world trade center et la
parution du livre
non vous exagérez qui les mena il a eu
le prix a été annoncé pas celui là qui a
eu le prix interallié sais c'est le
précédent c'est la française
le prix interallié c'est un prix que les
journalistes remettent à un journaliste
qui a écrit un livre on dit que c'est un
roman on dit que c'est le prix le plus
corrompu c'est vraiment le prix du
renvoi d'ascenseur vous le confirmer non
parce que depuis que j'en fais partie de
personnes a essayé de m'acheter c'est
mon grand drame
c'est pour ça que je n'aime pas mon
époque et mélange de laetitia avait reçu
le prix roger nimier qui était vraiment
à des uns des héros delà de votre
génération d'écrivains
est-ce que ça est ce que ça vous la
jouer dans votre dans votre dans la
fuite
abbas était très très content d'avoir le
prix lumière c'était comme
une espèce d'accomplissement la seule
chose qu'ils croyaient pas c'était
presque fait pour d'ailleurs c'était
j'ai tellement aimé les livres de nimier
des us à eux j'étais ravie et j'ai eu
aussi pris que les baladins ce pour un
autre livre disque il me semble r wella
essart et non c'est les prix oui j'en ai
vu énormément
heureusement maintenant je ne peux plus
en avoir parce que je les donne comme je
fais partie du riz sépare vertu pur que
je suis entré dans ces jurys ça
s'intitule donc les romans d'avant il y
en a trois on a seul volume
et ça vient de paraître chez albin
michel
[Musique]
vanessa benelli moselle vous êtes une
célèbre pianiste et désormais chef
d'orchestre et votre nouvel album casta
diva c'est de l'opéra jouer au piano le
piano une telle capacité lyrique et
orchestrale qu'il peut interpréter de
l'opéra à lui tout seul
enfin avec l'aide de sa pianiste
évidemment un oui absolument c'est un
projet qui marie justement les pianos et
l'opéra la fascination et l'enchantement
qu'est l'opéra italienne a suscité chez
des lions en du clavier a toujours été
sous mes yeux et a toujours suscité mon
intérêt c'est des transcriptions des
oeuvres qui nous étonne pour leur
virtuosité qui ait jamais en fait
finalisé à eux mêmes mais
il transcrit 7 passionne tous les
sentiments les personnages qui sont
allés dans l'opéra les tisanes les
personnages phase il
il ya tout dans l'opéra italienne et les
compositeurs et les grands interprètes
comme liszt et albert vous chopez on a
mis dans l'acte de t'inscrire ses thèmes
ses mélodies de l'opéra italien pour les
pianos on va reparler de l'art de la
transcription parce que c'est vraiment
cet album et est consacrée au fond à
l'art de la transcription
mais d'abord pour vous écouter norma de
bellini voilà un opéra extrêmement
célèbre chanter avec un orchestre
derrière et voilà ce que ça donne avec
juste un piano
[Musique]
on
oh
vanessa benelli moselle juste en deux
mots avant de faire une pause les pions
on y reviendra près mais expliquer
d'abord aux téléspectateurs ce que c'est
que la transcription comment on fait
pour transcrire tout un opéra avec
quantité de musiciens des chanteurs
comme on fait pour construire sa au
piano alors les pianos déjà à cette
ambition d'assimiler le répertoire
d'orchestre et
avait il ya une richesse sonore qui peut
associer à chaque touche est à chaque
saut à l'instrument dès lors qu est ici
aussi il peut transcrire les instruments
de leur caisse mais aussi la voix donc
c'est le seul instrument qui paie en
fait reproduire une partition si
complexe qui essaient de l'opéra en
donnant tout le monde la possibilité d
entendre ses thèmes et ses mélodies dans
une performance aux lenteurs métallerie
les récitals
l'ambition attribué justement à franz
liszt
mais comme on peut pas me mettre non
plus toutes les notes de tous les
instruments et de toutes les voix ont
fait un choix et ses salars de la
transcription au fait c'est le choix qui
a été fait là ce qu'on vient d'entendre
norma de bellini c'était thalberg qui
s'en est chargé je propose de faire une
pause on se retrouve juste après et on
continue de parler de l'art de la
transcription avec vanessa benelli
moselle
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec vanessa
benelli moselle qui sort casta diva gelé
10k stade yves assez de l'opéra jouer au
piano
on a parlé de de thalberg qui s'est
chargé de la transcription de normal le
célèbre opéra de bellini il y avait au
même moment son grand rival cette liste
il y avait également chopin on est au
19e siècle les pianistes sont des
superstars
on n'imagine pas un qui avait des
superstars à l'époque mais si c'était sa
liste il était aussi célèbre en europe
que les beatles peut-être enfin bon
peut-être pas sans exagérer mais mais
quand même et donc chaque liste stars
aussi à grand transcripteur on va on va
l'entendre pourquoi est ce qu'ils
avaient envie de jouer sur scène des
airs d'opéra après tout liste à composer
énormément de morceaux il pouvait se
passer de l'opéra oui effectivement
liste a toujours été fasciné par la
grandeur de 200 de leurs castres 1 ayant
déjà retranscrit les symphonies de
beethoven et aussi des airs d opéras de
wagner par exemple donc listes étaient
en grande interprète merci en grand
compositeur un grand pédagogue aussi une
figure très charismatique qui a frappé
tout le monde du romantisme allemand du
piano et jusqu'à maintenant l'intérêt
quand on était une superstar du piano un
virtuose comme liste comme comme
thalberg on se produisait partout les
gens voulaient absolument vous voir mais
il voulait aussi entendre les airs
d'opéra qui connaissaient ou pas
d'ailleurs parce que parfois ces airs
d'opéra en province on les entendait pas
voilà c'est aussi les bouts de la
transcription c'est d'amener justement
les thèmes et les mélodies de l'opéra en
provence où c'était plus difficile et
plus dures d'exporter une production
entière
vu les difficultés des voyages et se
déplacer une finalité que
malheureusement maintenant 2000
vingtaine
les transcriptions retrouve ces moments
un intendant des bleus produire sur
scène toute liberté
on va vous écoutez interpréter guillaume
tell célèbre opéra de rossini dans la
transcription de franz liszt de l'époque
un extrait
oh
il
on peut
e
non
vous
pas mal
vanessa benelli mzl vous êtes chef
d'orchestre aujourd'hui donc c'est opéra
vous pouvez les diriger alors est ce que
c'est parce qu'il ya le vide que vous ne
pouvait plus diriger d'opéra que vous
avez eu envie de faire ce disque où vous
les interprété au piano
oui je te dis la direction depuis deux
ans donc c'est une
nouvelle activité que j'ai envie de
développer encore plus malheureusement
l'écho vide ça va en plus difficile de
travailler avec les autres qu'est ce
donc avec beaucoup de monde sur scène et
donc les pianos est toujours là pour moi
très présent surtout en ce moment est
donc là l'opéra comme je les connais
très très jeune à 3 ans sur les jambes
de ma mère qui m'a emmené voir boris
godounov à florence et après j'ai donc
j'ai déjà nié ces corps d'enfants
chantant pour cinq ans dans un corps des
voiles blancs que j'ai connus vraiment
l'opéra de près et les backstage et
d'opéra m'a toujours fasciné et et
n'ayant toujours à jouer du père et
toute ma vie depuis l'âge de 13 ans je
voulais vraiment faire un projet qui
pourrait revenir ces demandes donc le
piano et l'opéra avec mes origines qui
sont des objets des origines italiennes
donc à donner la possibilité de
représenter aussi l'opéra italienne
autour du monde et voilà ça
malheureusement
voilà ça donne casta diva ce nouvel
album de vanessa benelli moselle la
dernière fois que vous avez joués en
public devant du vrai public c'était
qu'on hausse était un bon c'était cet
été car heureusement l'été on peut faire
des festivals en plein air donc il ya
beaucoup de public qui avait marché
avait beaucoup par l'idée
des suivre donc c'était
c'était en france en italie dans des
festivals d'été et
les fonctions vient nous suivent aussi
par streaming avec les concerts oui avec
les foncières en streaming que je viens
de faire par exemple avec les fers
monique de radio france la semaine
dernière donc vivement que ça revienne
en vrai casta diva donc le nouvel album
de vanessa benelli moselle merci vanessa
[Musique]
kabanda vous êtes historien vous êtes le
directeur du patrimoine de la fondation
napoléon 2021 celle 200e anniversaire de
la mort de napoléon 1er vous publiez un
gros livre de 650 pages chez perrin
napoléon à sainte-hélène vous rappeler
que jamais autant de moyens n'avait
encore été dévolu à la garde d'un seul
homme
c'était tout à fait nouveau est
exceptionnelle à cette époque
ah oui complètement en fait ce n'est pas
seulement une île prison qu'on a réservé
à napoléon mais tout un océan
l'atlantique sud en fait cet océan est
gardé par une flotte britannique et qui
est centrée sur la garde de ce
prisonnier exceptionnel 3000 hommes sont
envoyés à sainte hélène les îles
environnantes enfin environnantes elles
sont distantes de près d'un millier
l'eau m ascension et tristan d'un coup
nas ont pris part les britanniques enfin
je veux dire les britanniques ont
terrorisé par ce personnage exceptionnel
ont effectivement conçu une prison je
dirais à sa mesure
chi chi et lui ont réservé une partie du
globe en fait pour l'emprisonner c'est
dire leur crainte du personnage leurs
craintes extrême de ce personnage qui
les a surpris tant de fois au cours de
son existence alors en 1814 il avait été
exilé à l'île d'elbe
il aurait très bien pu finir ses jours
libre et souverain
s'il ne s'était pas lancé dans la
reconquête absurde de son empire
les fameux 100 jours qu'on aime beaucoup
en france mais si qui sont quand même
une entreprise totalement totalement
désespéré vouée à l'échec ça s'est
terminé par waterloo ça a coûté à la
france très très cher est ce qui lui est
arrivé alors qu'il était à l'aise
certaines aides ce qui lui est arrivé de
le regretter de le regretter de ne pas
être resté à lille oui ben oui
plusieurs jours anniversaire il a dit
nous étions en ce moment là à l'île
d'elle il ya un an nous étions aux lib
dems étions beaucoup mieux c'est vrai à
ce moment là près de la ligne d'albi
près de la corse ça lui rappelle son
enfance c'est un cadre ensoleillé
tranquille mais vain en réalité pas si
tranquille que ça hélas il était déjà
menacé en fait on sait maintenant que
des complots et une alliance visé à se
débarrasser de lui ainsi que son beau
frère installé à naples le mur a donc en
fait et il est certes il a tenté une
aventure désespérée mais il n'a pas eu
vraiment le choix non plus et comme
toujours à napoléon il fallait qu'ils se
sortent par lui-même qu'il écrive par
lui-même son destin
c'est la caractéristique du personnage
est en fait il était prisonnier aussi de
cette île d'elbe
quelque part il a voulu s'en échapper en
tentant une solution inouïe aventureuse
qui au départ a fonctionné puisqu'il a
repris le pouvoir sans tirer un coup de
fusil et se réinstalle sur son trône
mais enfin qui finit par la base a été
renommé napoléon ce personnage
imprévisible c'est difficile finalement
qui n'a pas de limites c'est difficile
de lui en fixer parce que sinon il
n'aurait pas été jusqu aux pyramides ils
n'auraient pas été jusqu'à moscou
en fait il n'a pas comme ça il a
toujours tenté des choses absolument
folle souvent au départ il les a réussis
évidemment à la fin il perd mais la
caractéristique du personnage c'est de
toujours tenté tenté d'oser encore et
d'écrire sa propre histoire lui même
sens sans cela faire dicter ce qui est
assez rare pour un individu est
justement il ya un moment où il ne
touche rien où ils n'osent pas d'appeler
on vous le raconter en détails de votre
livre c'est le 3 juillet 1815 napoléon
n'a que 45 ans à ce moment là il faut
bien voir sais c'est pas un tout jeune
homme mais est dans la force de l'âge il
a perdu la bataille de waterloo
il a signé son abdication et il veut
partir aux etats-unis et il arrive à
rochefort là où on tournera plus tard
les deux demoiselles de rochefort le 3
juillet avec sa suite il a beaucoup
d'argent à sa disposition c'était le
souverain le plus riche d'europe 1
appelé on est plusieurs millions donc
sont disponibles des bateaux sont prêts
pourquoi ne peuvent-ils pas aux états
unis comme il en avait et l'occasion
l'opportunité et le désir
oui le moment là il
impossibilité passé aux états unis mais
de manière assez clandestine la flotte
britannique bloquent les accès maritimes
donc s'il peut passer en effet mais ce
sera à la faveur voilà d'une nouvelle
aventure
il ne veut plus temps telle aventure il
cherche quelque chose d'autre il a peur
ils sont entrés sans une aventure qui
pourrait être raté et un appelé ans il a
écrit le roman de sa vie
faut-il encore bien le terminer ce roman
donc il faut que il trouve une fin digne
de lui et à ce moment-là il estime que
tenter l aventure dans ces conditions
sur un navire de commerce peut être être
pris comme un pirate risquer de nuire
déjà à sa personne mais aussi sa légende
donc en fait il va à nouveau rebattre
les cartes et tenter un pari fou qu'il a
et il va perdre ses se rendre aux
anglais pour les obliger le traité
dignement finalement par un geste
chevaleresque et s'établir à londres que
napoléon est un personnage qui peut
changer d'avis de et de stratégie en 24
heures il l'a prouvé plusieurs fois et
là il tente autre chose plus josé
finalement même que de passer en
amérique mais pour lui c'est une
solution qui lui paraît plus digne et
qui comme ça permet de continuer en
quelque sorte d'écriture c'est les
jambes
oui parce que vous raconter tout les
projets d'évasion
là c'était le 3 juillet il y avait des
bateaux bon il serait parti c'était
risqué mais bon mais après quand il rate
le départ du 3 juillet on lui propose
encore beaucoup de deux plans d'évasion
et de
dont un à bord d'un navire marchand où
il se serait glissée dans un tonneau
alors il dit oui il aime ça ça on
comprend bien que ça lui déplaît l'idée
de finir dans le tonneau il a peur de se
noyer
mais le bateau part sans lui et le
bateau par les anglais ni ni welsh pas
ça aurait marché
il aurait pu sortir de ce bateau aux
états unis libre on n'imagine pas ce que
ça aurait pu donner il ya il ya l'autre
projet qui aurait il serait qui se
serait terminée de la même façon c'est
son frère joseph qui est prêt à partir
aux etats-unis qui a une place sur un
bateau et qui lui propose de se rendre à
sa place c'est elle qui se ressemblaient
beaucoup et le temps que les anglais
réalise qu'ils avaient joseph et pas
d'appeler ou napoléon lui serait parti
aux états unis sur le bateau tout à fait
légalement à la place de joseph et là
aussi le raid débarquer aux états c'est
un petit jeu auquel on s'est livré est
d'ailleurs aussi débat que serait
devenue napoléon aux états unis oui
c'est vrai puis tout aurait été possible
se serait-il lancer à la conquête de
l'ouest et deux nuls ont-ils servi la
jeune république américaine tout est
possible en effet elle son frère est
arrivé aux etats-unis
il restait longtemps mais il n'était pas
proscrit comme comme napoléon et
napoléon tenait aussi à son rang
d'empereur donc au fait vous l'avez dit
dans un tonneau conserver son empereur
c'est un petit peu difficile
quelle que soit la qualité du tonneau et
il veut quand même partir avec une
petite cour avec des serviteurs il tient
tout cela en fait il est empereur il
veut aussi sauvegarder sa dynastie et il
ne veut pas partir comme ça exagérément
l aventure c'est le souverain et
l'empereur finement qui l'emportent et
qui comme un souverain se rend à celui
qui l'a vaincu il veut sortir la tête
haute qui seront donc aux anglais mais
il faut dire aussi qu'ils ne se doute
pas de ce qui l'attend c'est à dire la
déportation ah non pas du tout non il
n'a pas du tout calcul est il qu'il
allait être déporté à sainte hélène il
est persuadé de s'établir à l'ombre
d'être peut-être surveiller mais met
d'ailleurs dans son message au prince
régent un georges le futur george iv il
dit je viens comme thémistocle m'asseoir
au sein du foyer britannique thémistocle
c'est un général romain qui s'était
rendu aux perses comme lui qui avait été
battu mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que thémistocle ensuite servi les perses
et a gagné des batailles et des
campagnes pour eux alors est ce que
napoléon est venu leur dire mais si vous
voulez utiliser et finalement que je
sais que vous servent bien peut-être je
suis disponible
s'il l'avait nommé vice roi des indes
peut-être on ne sait pas avec lui
tout tout tout est possible il s'était
fort bien entendu l'année précédente
avec les anglais il avait une
fascination pour leur marine justifiée
parce que c'était la meilleure de
l'époque
mais encore une fois c'est difficile
d'anticiper ou de dire ce qu'il aurait
pu faire à ce moment-là parce que
napoléon est toujours surprenant et
toutes les solutions tout ce qu'il a pu
faire est rien était prévisible c'est
lui qui est dit impossible n'est pas
français en fête est aussi impossible
n'est pas napoléon car voilà il a c'est
le personnage qui qui était l'un des
plus surprenants de l'histoire
alors là c'est plutôt lui qui est
surpris quand on le met sur un bateau
pour partir il ya deux mois plus de deux
mois de voyage pour sainte hélène une
île dont kate à 8000 kilomètres de
l'europe à 3000 kilomètres de l'amérique
du sud sur les côtes brésiliennes qui
sont les plus proches
trois mille kilomètres quand même et
2000 km de l'afrique
donc il est vraiment absolument perdu
sur un caillou qui a eu l'idée de sainte
hélène
alors c'est le premier ministre lors
d'hivers paul dirigeant des
conservateurs anglais qui très hostile à
napoléon a pris cette décision parce que
il faut pouvoir sécuriser empêcher que
napoléon puisse s'évader où il sera
ensuite on veut on ne veut pas qu'il
aille en angleterre non plus parce qu'à
ce moment là il ya quand même des droits
juridiques dans ce pays le fameux habeas
corpus donc napoléon aurait pu se
défendre juridiquement avoir un avocat
et c'était avant que ça ils ne veulent
pas ou sainte hélène
qui appartient à la compagnie des ânes
ne bénéficient pas de la baisse corpus
est en fait surtout on pense aussi
l'éloigner les douaniers du peuple
britannique ce qui est quand même un
paradoxe parce qu'il est populaire en
angleterre quand il est apparu près des
côtes anglaises avant d'être déportée à
sainte-hélène des milliers de personnes
sont venues l'acclamer
on s'est même noyé pour approcher sans
son navire et on l'acclamé
alors que le gouvernement conservateur
dirigé par liverpool était très
impopulaire lui donc en fait ils ont eu
peur de cette figure qui de cet homme
très populaire et donc on l'éloignant à
sainte hélène ont pensé le réduire au
silence
et ainsi empêcher qu'ils puissent
continuer à séduire les foules et
pourquoi pas revenir là le réduire au
silence ils vont pas y parvenir un ni
même à ce qu on l'oubli parce que ça
aussi voulu explique voulu raconter eu
un débutant l'envoyant à sainte-hélène
c'est qu'on va l'oublier et et non
seulement va pas l'oublier mais on va
pas le réduire au silence
vous dites que on sait qu'il va écrire
ses mémoires ce qui va devenir le
mémorial de sainte-hélène mais qui ne
paraîtra qu'en 1823 donc deux ans après
sa disparition
mais avant ça il a réussi à appuyer a
publié plusieurs écrits en france et en
angleterre il ya des écrits de napoléon
qui régulièrement entre 1815 1818 sont
publiés en angleterre et lui valent des
sympathies oui c'est tout à fait
étonnant en fait le l'homme le plus
regardé au monde publient des
l'équivalent de deux plusieurs centaines
de pages en angleterre à londres à
quelques centaines de mètres des
ministères anglais alors sous anonymat
m'enfin il il arrive à crédibiliser son
propos par diverses astuces mais enfin
toujours est il que les anglais sont
totalement mystifié et que ses livres
marche fort en angleterre sont vendus sa
parole c'est diffuse et on et à la barbe
de ses geôliers ans et c'est une
véritable prouesse effectivement il
pensait le réduire au silence c'est tout
le contraire
on ne fait que parler de lui dans la
presse les tout ce qui est tous les
livres qui ont rapport à sa personne
fonctionnant liés en librairie sont
vendus il ya un engouement il ya même à
londres une exposition 1816 qui est
consacrée à napoléon au tour de la
berline de sa berline de campagne qui
avait été prise à waterloo et
l'exposition fait deux cent mille
visiteurs payants elle fera presque un
million de visiteurs en angleterre et je
veux dire et tout ça donc en fait pour
le gouvernement britannique celui qui
devait être oubliée
les librairies sont pleines de ses
livres les gens font la queue pour
admirer ces objets tout ça quelque part
à quelques pas pardon les mystères
anglais c'est une véritable surprise des
déconvenues en fait et au lieu de se
faire oublier on ne cessera de parler de
lui des conditions de la captivité et de
sainte hélène est il dans quel but
à ce moment là quel est le but de
napoléon qu'est-ce qui l'animent
on a l'impression en vous lisant il va
faire ça jusqu en 1818 à peu près et
puis après il va arrêter
donc il va veut dire que il espère
encore être libérés c'est ça hein
il espère que le peuple va du mans une
bonne partie de l'opinion va prendre
fait et cause en sa faveur et qui va il
obtiendra sa libération
oui parce qu'en fait ils espèrent que un
mouvement populaire se dessine en sa
faveur en faveur des libéraux
les opposants au gouvernement liverpool
et que ceux ci arriveront d'une manière
ou d'une autre à prendre le pouvoir et
le rappellerons en angleterre ou en
europe enfin le sortiront de
sainte-hélène son calcul mais loin
d'être idiot parce que effectivement les
libéraux arriveront pouvoir mais
seulement en 1830 fallu qu'ils vivent
jusque là et comme ils sont en sa faveur
et qui n'arrêtent pas d'ailleurs de de
contester sa déportation et bien il
aurait sans doute modifier les
conditions de sa détention sans doute
lui aurait-il enlevé mais aurait-il mis
ailleurs en fait donc ce sont calculées
et pertinents il va lui manquer du temps
le gouvernement conservateur va
finalement résisté va employer la force
contre les contre certaines émeutes
parce que le pays l'angleterre on
l'oublié souvent mais à ce moment là est
au bord de la révolution les historiens
britanniques l'ont bien elles ont bien
mis en évidence aujourd'hui c'est par
exemple le massacre de peter l'eau des
ouvrières il ya une répression assez
sévère mais enfin toujours est il que ça
tient et que le calcul de napoléon sera
perdant mais toujours est il que il
était il restait possible est en fait
une poursuite pas une chimère il y croit
dur comme fer et même il va y croire
encore c'est vrai qu'il y croit de moins
en moins parce qu'il est affecté par les
départs par le le congrès d'aix la
chapelle théo au cours duquel les
puissants alliés vont confirmer cette
détention à sainte hélène en fait quand
même en avril 1921 et à quelques
semaines de mourir il entend le signal
qui annonce l'arrivée d'un bateau dans
le port de djen stone et ce qui
signifiait l'arrivée de journaux et il
dit son entourage ça y est des journaux
vont arriver je suis sûr que le
gouvernement conservateur est tombé
qu'un gouvernement libéral est arrivé je
suis sûr que nous rentrons quelques
semaines plus tard il est mort voilà
donc jusqu'au bout il le conserve une
forme d' espérant même si celle-ci
s'amenuisent au fil des années c'est
certain alors libéral c'est exactement
l'image qui va vouloir donner de lui à
travers ses écrits et notamment à
travers le mémorial de sainte-hélène un
héros de la révolution
ce serait la révolution qu'il aurait
voulu exporter en europe
il aurait été lui-même très libéral tout
cet institut de fadaises quoi c'est pas
du tout non non non dire que la polarité
libéral effectivement c'est un peu c'est
difficile à la firme est en fait c'est
une alliance de circonstance entre
napoléon et libéraux qui se qui se
nouent comme ça du autant de la
captivité qui va se poursuivre après
c'est cette image qui va rester
d'ailleurs n'a pas l'air lorsqu'il dicte
ses mémoires prend bien soin de raconter
le général de la révolution au l'italie
l'egypte et puis il passe directement au
sens jour là au moment de l' empire
libéral il n'a pu l'oublier un peu tout
le milieu va quand même pratiquement
quinze ans où là il ya eu quand même
enfin le libéralisme avec lui c'est
petit à petit rétréci mais enfin l'or
pour se justifier les libéraux
politiquement parce qu'on va leur dire
oui mais quand même et il n'était pas
très libéral a dit oui mais je veux dire
il avait des idées libérales mais il a
été obligé de mettre en place de l'ordre
avant et le libéralisme il l'aurait mis
après donc enfin c'est un petit peu
raccourci un peu facile politique qu'on
peut trouver d'ailleurs toujours
aujourd'hui
mais cette alliance finalement de
circonstance va durer et laisser cette
image
pour populariser en effet par le
mémorial de las cases qui présente un
atelier avec des idées totalement
libérale ce qui est effectivement très
tirée par les cheveux exagéré dernière
question qui a banda parce qu'il ya
tellement de choses dans ce livre il est
énorme
son héritage il avait plusieurs millions
au moment où il applique et où il pense
à partir des états unis il avait
beaucoup d'argent napoléon du temps
qu'il était empereur qu'est-ce que cet
argent est devenu alors il a souhaité
récompenser tout ce qu'il en série tous
les fidèles de son épopée alors les
premiers sont ceux qui l'ont accompagné
à sainte-hélène montholon bertrand qu'il
remercie de manière un peu différente
surtout le c'est surtout mon taux longs
qui remporte le gros morceau près de
deux millions de francs mais enfin il va
remercier tous ceux qui au long de sa
vie l'ont véritablement aidé et en fait
par contre point on peut en déduire que
tous ceux qui ne sont pas dans son
testament est bien long un moment ou un
autre de son point de vue trahi en fait
à napoléon dresse une sorte de bilan
humain de son épopée en léguant des
centaines de milliers de francs alain
puis à l'autre ou descendants des uns et
des autres quand son plein le personnage
était mort donc en fait c'est vraiment
une
un point final dernier message de
napoléon mais sa liste du fidèle en fait
sorte de monument aux fidèles napolioni
incontestable et incontesté pour lui il
y en a en tout 70 qui fait le pas
beaucoup pour une vie aussi riche que la
sienne
merci pierre bordas napoléon à l'inversé
rennes vient de paraître chez perrin
merci tous les trois merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]